guy throwing passes in cleveland baker
mayfield created the storm unwittingly
on tuesday chris this broke late in the
program it ended up generating plenty of
sound and content at pft all day long on
tuesday the baker mayfield comments
about daniel jones to gq magazine baker
mayfield told reporters on wednesday
that he reached out to daniel jones to
clear the air not that the air needed to
be cleared because daniel jones didn't
seem to be upset mayfield was upset
about what happened yeah here's what he
said as to what he told daniel jones
it seemed uh very disrespectful and i
can understand that but what people
didn't realize is the conversation
entailed of me saying that i was
surprised i was drafted number one
overall too and then me going on a rant
after that about
qb evaluation and then me frustration
from recruiting processes and stuff that
i've had that i've you know it's very
well documented my thoughts on a lot of
that and so
it had nothing to do specifically about
daniel about the winning and stuff but
you know i reached out to daniel because
all that blew out of you know way out of
hand and i wanted him to know how i felt
and i've heard nothing but great things
from saquon and sterling shepard
guys that you know have a lot of respect
for him and that i you know respect
their opinions and so i just wanted to
clear the air with him
you know initially baker mayfield said
on social media he didn't say it but
then he said i also said that i was
surprised that was the first overall
pick look bottom line is he said it but
it was part of a broader
and and again the one thing that
mayfield did not say publicly and maybe
he doesn't want to say
or admit or reveal that he was naive the
bottom line is this he didn't know that
the interview was happening exactly
that's the reality and we talked about
that the other day that's one of the
benefits when gq dangles that photo
shoot and cover every year to one nfl
player and part of that is hey you got
to go have lunch with our guy
these guys don't realize right and and
they learn the hard way that anything
you say can and will be used against you
and that's exactly what happened to
baker mayfield just like it happened
last year to jalen ranch yeah that's
right it's just not a normal nfl
interview for what players are used to
like if you get interviewed by peter
king he's gonna you might talk for a
minute and say some things off the cuff
that you know are not gonna be
publicized and then at some point you
sit down and he turns on the tape
recorder and you go okay now the
interview starts right there's a little
bit of an unwritten rule there i'm sure
gq they're not all into the sports
scenes maybe they don't know that they
also probably enjoy kind of tricking
guys this way they know yeah they know
what they're doing they do know what
they're doing but either way
another piece of evidence of the
maturity the leadership the man baker
mayfield is yeah he messed up a little
bit he got a little loose with his lips
and not talking and whatever else and
i'm sure it was taken out of context to
a degree but he confronts situations
head-on handles them squashes it makes a
phone call that's what a real man does
and i i really appreciate that aspect of
him that he just is not one that's gonna
hide away from it or try to bs his way
out of a situation
now you know last year i loved how
jaylen ramsey handled it he didn't even
come out and try to defend any of it he
owned it and when i had a chance to
interview him a couple of months later
he said i learned from it because you
don't realize when you're talking to
these people everything you say is fair
game and that off the record exception
you know that that's for folks who have
been around the block a few times not
guys in their early 20s who don't even
know what on the record or off the
record quite mean hell i didn't know it
until i was in my 40s
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports